)
- Au pied de l'Arc de Triomphe,
un convoi qui bloque plusieurs
voies. Des automobilistes et
motocyd'un peu partout au pays c
différentes revendications
à faire entendre.
- (en criant:) On veut
(klaxons)
- Pour la liberté, pour la fin
des mesures sanitaires qui
ne tiennent pas debout.
consomme, sauf les salaires qui,
eux, n'augmentent pas.
- Des protestataires qui
ont ignoré l'interdictioncrcrcrr
les autorités. Les forces
de l'ordre, très présentes,
n'ont pas ménagé les moyensisis:
des véhicules remorqués et
des policiers antiémeutes
déployés. Des gaz lacrymogènesst
même les clients de cafés
avoisinants. C'est sans compter
les efforts des autorités pourrr
dans Paris. Depuis vendredi
dans la périphérie,
des véhicules sont contrôlés,
de
DIDIER LALLEMENT,
préfetpopopolice de Paris
- La détermination des forces
de s
est entière. Le niveau de
mosasasation est significatif.
- La préfecture de police
les sanctions liées à
tttttttte manifestation.
Entraver la circulation est
et de deux ans d'emprisonnemenÇ,
ça fait peur. Mais, il y a
des
Il y a plus que l'argent,
plus que le confort.
- Des coups d'éclat sporadiques
dans une capitale où,
la vie quotidienne
n'a pas été paralysée,
mais une frustration bien réelle
un contexte politique sensible.
- Faites l'apapapapas la guerre,
les gars!
(klaxons)
- Ce Parisien, qui espérait
saluer certains ananananants,
rappelle que l'élection
présidentielle
à grands pas.
- La suit t t t t dans
trois mois ou dans deux mois
dans l
- Après Paris, certains
part     à ces convois
ont un autre objectif :
ils souhaiteààààààààààààààààààùu
ils pourraient être rejoints
par des manifestants venus
d'ailleurs en Europe.
elles aussi, déjà annoncé